une de mes meilleures amies et
ukrainienne
elle s'appelle anastasia coutier rinko
elle est doctorant en informatique à le
pfl et elle est peut-être la personne le
plus gentil plus heureuse et la plus
enthousiaste que je connaisse
jusqu'à récemment
l'invasion de l'ukraine l'a dévasté
tellement pleuré ne pouvait plus manger
ne pouvait plus dormir
et elle ne s'essaie de s'inquiéter car
beaucoup de ses amis et de sa famille
sont restés en ukraine où la guerre est
malheureusement toujours
en cours
en fait nous des filles à qui anastasia
enseigner les mathématiques
est morte
de la guerre
la guerre est tragique
la guerre est
inhumaine
non seulement pour les milliers de
personnes qui sont déjà mortes
mais aussi pour les millions
d'ukrainiens qui sont soudainement
devenus
des sans abri
deux semaines anastasia a trouvé le
courage l'énergie incroyable de partager
son expérience dans le cadre du concours
ma thèse en trois minutes à le pfl
je ne peux pas suffisamment insisté sur
la difficulté de l'exercice pour elle
sachant ce qu'elle était en train de
vivre
quelques heures avant l'exposé
elle était tellement épuisé mentalement
et physiquement
quel doutaient de sa capacité
à faire sa présentation
mais elle a fait
et elle a fait
incroyablement bien sans plus attendre
voici le discours fantastique et
déchirant qu'elle a donnée
j'ai mis anastasia dans la description
ainsi que de nombreuses sources pour
étayer ses affirmations
je vous invite à les consulter
la désinformation de masse
a pris une ampleur alarmante
tout comme les appels à la haine à la
violence
et même trop souvent au génocide
nous vivons une guerre mondiale de la
désinformation de masse
et comme l'a dit anastasia tant que
cette guerre a lieu
personne n'est à l'abri
d'autant plus dans le contexte de crise
économique à venir causés par la
pandémie decaux vide et la guerre en
ukraine où le risque d'assister à des
famines tragique à travers le monde
malheureusement à l'heure actuelle
l'écrasante majorité est entre nous est
loin de se soucier suffisamment de cette
guerre de désinformation massive
même au sein de la communauté
scientifique
et même en informatique
j'insiste sur informatique en
particulier car les informaticiens
oublie trop souvent à ma grande
frustration
qu'il n'ait tu dis rien d'autre que la
science du traitement et de la
communication de l'information en tant
que communauté que nous le voulions ou
non
nous donne du pouvoir aux technologies
de l'information et à ceux qui
contrôlent ces technologies
des technologies qui sont trop souvent
dangereusement détourné par les troupes
de la guerre de la désinformation
dès lors il me semble qu'il s'agit d'une
faute morale que de poursuivre nos
travaux quotidiens comme si de rien
n'était
alors que de toute évidence
une grande partie des technologies que
nous contribuerons à développer
sont utilisées par des dictateurs pour
répandre la haine
manipuler les croyances des populations
et harceler les détracteurs avec ce que
j'appelle du pont barre de man
psychologique
un autre de mes amis subit actuellement
un bombardement psychologique à grande
échelle très dangereux pour avoir
défendu la paix et la vérité mais j'en
parlerais davantage une autre fois
d'ailleurs dans cette série nous avons
déjà vu en quoi mark zuckerberg s'est
comporté de manière criminelle à de
nombreuses reprises en facilitant le
trafic d'êtres humains et en
encourageant les discours de haine et de
guerre en modifiant notamment son
algorithme de recommandation
ce que zuckerberg a fait ce n'est pas
seulement immoral
c'est également illégal
zuckerberg est poursuivi en justice
j'espère que justice sera faite ce qui
signifie que s'il est reconnu coupable
de ses actes
il doit être mis en prison
explique sophie zinc
lanceuse d'alert de facebook
facebook est devenu complice par son
inaction dans cette répression
autoritaire
la décision effective a été prise de ne
pas en faire une priorité
ferment effectivement
les yeux
malheureusement l'écrasante majorité
du monde universitaire
notamment dans la recherche en
intelligence artificielle
ne fait pas beaucoup mieux que les
dirigeants de facebook
beaucoup trop de chercheurs du domaine
décide chaque jour
de ne pas prioriser la recherche contre
les campagnes de guerre de
désinformation
fermant ainsi effectivement les yeux
alors même que des génocides ont été
facilités par les discours de haine
amplifié
par nos technologies notamment en
ethiopie
où un demi million de personnes ont été
assassinées
et alors que cinq millions de civils
sont actuellement assiégé et ce depuis
un an et demi
et meurent de faim
et de maladie
j'ai profondément
profondément honte
de ma communauté de recherche
en poursuivant des collaborations avec
des organisations comme google et
facebook
en contribuant à leur technologie
dangereuse
et on ne prétend pas sa tension en tout
cas pas suffisamment attention aux
effets secondaires catastrophique de
notre activité
nous nous comportons
comme des criminels
en fait c'est pire que cela
encore et toujours lorsqu'il s'agit
d'alu et les fonds de recherche
d'attirer les meilleurs étudiants de
présenter dans des conférences de
décider des orientations de la recherche
ou d'évaluer les articles de recherche
de nos pères
trop souvent à l'heure actuelle
les chercheurs sont peu au cou trop
heureux de promouvoir les performances à
la pointe du progrès dans des contextes
pourtant irréalistes ou aucune campagne
de guerre de désinformation n'attaque
leur système et sans tenir compte des
conséquences du déploiement réel de
leurs technologies
notre recherche académique est en train
d' encourager et accélérer le
déploiement de technologies est
extrêmement dangereuse avant tout est
approfondie et trop souvent sans aucune
analyse de sécurité
c'est criminelle
chaque fois que vous en tant que
chercheur impôts 10 et les progrès de la
recherche sur l'ia non sécurisés
tenez compte du fait
que pour reprendre les termes de
suffisance
vous êtes en train de fermer
effectivement les yeux et de fermer les
yeux de votre public sur les millions de
tragédie humaine qui se produisent dans
le monde à cause en partie le système
d'intelligence artificielle
non sécurisée et en particulier des
algorithmes de recommandations qui
amplifie considérablement la haine et la
violences
pires encore à chaque fois que vous
battez l'état dollars avec des
algorithmes toujours plus complexes
rendez vous bien compte que vous êtes en
train de rendre plus difficile la tâche
de chercheurs en sécurité de
l'intelligence artificielle comme moi à
qui l'on demande de concevoir des
algorithmes sécurisé aux performances
comparables en fait nos articles ont été
qualifiées à plusieurs reprises de
restrictif
simplement parce qu'ils exigent une
surcharge de calcul par rapport aux
algorithmes de l'état de l'art
ce n'est pas une blague la recherche
académique actuelle en particulier en
intelligence artificielle est trop
souvent obsédé par la performance plutôt
que par la sécurité au point que
sacrifier un peu de performances est
parfois considéré complètement
irréaliste par certains chercheurs à qui
j'ai discuté
irréaliste ça me met hors de moi
alors que je dirais que la plupart des
articles en machine learning sont
beaucoup plus irréaliste encore
notamment car il s'appuie sur
l'hypothèse irréaliste que toutes les
données sont tirées indépendamment d'une
distribution mystique inconnue et que
tous les participants à l'apprentissage
se comporte de manière complètement
honnête et digne de confiance
il est alarmant de constater que chaque
jour des dizaines de nouveaux
algorithmes sont proposés et sont
optimisés pour ce cadre qu'ont
irréaliste pour des applications à
grande échelle et qu'une poignée de
chercheurs seulement se charge d'étudier
leur vulnérabilité
qui plus est vous lors de man de
sécuriser les algorithmes sans jamais
compromettre leur performance cette
situation n'est absolument pas viable
cela a déjà conduit et conduira encore
inévitablement à des défaillances de
sécurité extrêmement dangereuse des
systèmes d'information les plus
influents du monde que les campagnes de
guerre de désinformation exploiter déjà
allègrement pour diviser davantage les
sociétés et accroître les tensions
mais ce qui me frustre le plus c'est de
voir
tous ces prix ont cerveau qui pourrait
être si précieux pour la recherche sur
la sécurité et l'éthique des algorithmes
tous et s'y pliant cerveau qui sont
actuellement davantage attirés par des
recherches soient inutiles soit même
profondément dangereuse si vous faites
de la recherche en mathématiques ou en
informatique
je vous en supplie
pensez aux externalités de vos activités
vous êtes payé pour vivre de votre
passion pendant que des millions
d'humains à travers le monde subissent
la haine amplifié par les algorithmes de
recommandations dont le déploiement est
parfois précipités par certaines de vos
recherches
en particulier à chaque fois que vous
demandez à vos collaborateurs de
travailler sur un sujet donné
dites vous que vous leur demandez
également de ne pas travailler sur des
sujets potentiellement beaucoup plus
important
s'il vous plaît au minimum
ne les conduisait pas de les obliger pas
à fermer effectivement les yeux sur les
souffrances causées par leurs activités
de recherche
s'il vous plaît
envisager plutôt de contribuer à des
programmes de recherche qui vise à
résoudre la crise de la désinformation
et de la haine
comme notre projet tournesol
pour rappel tournesol est une plateforme
en ligne conçu par l'association à but
non lucratif tournesol
et dont le but est d'identifier et
d'amplifier de manière collaborative et
sécurisée des contenus d'utilité
publique de qualité
il y a tellement de recherche qui sont
si importantes a effectué aujourd'hui
mais que nous ne parvenons pas à aborder
simplement parce que nous manquons de
fonds et de main d'oeuvre pour les
aborder
en fait même si vous n'êtes pas un
chercheur nous avons désespérément
besoin de votre aide pour contribuer à
augmenter notre base de données publique
de jugement éthique d'humains je vous en
supplie aidez nous à faire de cette base
de données un outil précieux pour les
chercheurs en machine learning afin de
rediriger leur attention vers la
conception d'algorithmes sécurisé et
éthiques plutôt que vers des recherches
inutiles ou potentiellement dangereuses
rendre la recherche académique beaucoup
plus éthique est tellement important
pour combattre efficacement la
propagation massive de la haine et de à
des informations et pour empêcher la
prolifération de guerre tant heureuse
avec des armes potentiellement de
destruction massif
vous pouvez aussi nous aider en nous
faisant des dons financiers pour payer
nos fantastiques développeurs mais aussi
plus simplement en comprenant notre
démarche et ont contribué à la faire
connaître et à l'expliquer notamment
auprès de votre entourage ou en
répondant aux questions sur notre
discorde ou sur les autres réseaux
sociaux
nous avons désespérément besoin de
toutes sortes dead comme l'ex si bien
anastasia la lutte contre les campagnes
de désinformation ne consiste pas
seulement à protéger les victimes des
guerres actuelles en fait il n'est pas
nécessaire d'être altruiste pour être
terrifiés par les conséquences de
l'amplification massive de la haine et
de la violence quel que soit le pays
dans lequel vous vivez actuellement même
en suisse vous devriez être terrifié par
la montée de la haine et de la violence
notamment à cause de désinformation et
yoko vide souvent motivée par de la
colère ou à cause de l'énorme crise
économique à venir ou encore parce
qu'une puissance étrangère nucléaire
pourrait éventuellement s'en prendre à
votre pays
si vous ne le faites pas pour les
millions de victimes de guerre a
actuellement en ukraine en ethiopie au
yémen
faites le au moins pour votre propre
bien et pour la sécurité de vos proches
s'il vous plaît dites non à la recherche
sur la performance
et s'il vous plaît encouragé beaucoup
plus massivement la recherche à sécurité
et l'éthique des algorithmes afin de
pouvoir beaucoup plus massivement
l'information fiable la bienveillance
les appels à la paix
je vous en supplie
l'avenir de toute l'humanité
est en jeu